[Music]
um what would you say are I asked this
to every guest red flags and girls yeah
like in dating like red flags like howdy
belly buttons I don't like that
what is that a result of like getting
the umbilical cord cut wrong Kaiser
Permanente birth
I've been to Kaiser Permanente dude that
place should not I have umbrella
insurance so I'm happy it's a lot of
Audi belly buttons there I went to
Kaiser Permanente once I fell off a
horse it was like it was a situation
where it was like an equine therapy
session there were kids there I'm
sitting on a horse and there's a kid on
it a peacock flies out of nowhere
peacocks are dicks and they fly out of
nowhere and the horse Spooks and I know
I'm gonna either I'm gonna the kid's
gonna fall and we're both gonna fall so
I'm like I just slowly like slide off
the back and hold the kid and the worst
thing you can do when you fall off a
horse is put your hands down but I grew
up on horses so it's like I knew so I
just slid and fell like holding the kid
18 hands tall horse like my ass hit the
ground I was like I broke my tailbone I
was like I don't I've never had this I
just know that was it I couldn't walk I
had to like crawl to my car I drove
myself to Kaiser Permanente I was like
my eyes have been broken God this is
gonna be so I'm gonna have to sit on a
donut like this is gonna be so bad I get
to Kaiser Permanente they x-ray me and
he's like you uh cracked her L4 okay
which is like one of your vertebrae and
there's like X-ray and I'm like it's
like you might be able to get surgery
but you probably just have to do
physical therapy there's no real and I'm
like you know been in the fucking
waiting room for six and a half hours
and I'm like I need a fucking story and
I was like can I
can I take a picture of the X-ray like
can I just whatever I'm like in content
brain and I'm like can I just like take
a picture you know and I gotta take a
pic he's like no and normally allowed to
do this but you're you so we'll let you
whatever which is the first red flag why
are you like oh we'll break our
hypocratic oath for a comedian like yeah
yeah and I and I go to take a picture of
it and I was like wait a second is that
he was like yeah see that right there
that's the that's the crack in your L4
and I was like
that's my IUD
what it was it's like a u-shape yeah you
could see the ribbon there's a little
tie on it and he was like oh and I was
like what
what
sir
damn that's crazy it was why and I was
like do I go to Yelp like what do I do
here and then a friend of mine guys like
a like a a broke vertebra it's like a
little bit of a like it's like a like a
like a safety pin kind of like like a
little u-shape but it has a little piece
of rope on it like a tiny piece of like
dental floss kind of thing I'm like
don't you see that thing he's like oh
yeah I figured it was just like two I'm
like what the fuck did you guys go to
the University of Phoenix online medical
school like how is it how does this and
then a friend of mine went to um Kaiser
Permanente uh uh had HPV because I guess
that shit's rampant now but basically
said to her oh everyone everyone's
getting it there's nothing you can do
about it that's not a statistic that's
crazy you can't just say ah everyone's
getting it there's nothing you can do
like there's no point there's nothing it
wouldn't even treat her it was like
everyone gets it now and it's like
that's not a statistic there's no way
that's legal to just say that to someone
to just dismiss them and be like ah
you're a whore like the rest of them wow
wow I don't fuck with Kaiser Permanente
anymore although they do have the rabies
vaccine and I got it recently for real
yeah hey do you fuck with them urgent
cares them niggas is lit I used to go to
urgent care quite a bit yeah why well
just because like UTIs you know or yeah
man yeah when you have sex with a new
guy it's like always the UTI situation
yeah just like getting the preventative
or if you go on antibiotics you got to
get probiotics or you get a yeast
infection so I would definitely roll
through Urgent Care just to get get
stocked up on that we nasty out here why
what are you going to urgent care for
and is that all just a country why do I
feel just hang out why doesn't Urgent
Care have like a psychiatric unit that's
just like a quick like I'm not doing
good
I think I should start another podcast
can you help
yo I didn't they have a psychiatric
Union no they should oh like urgent all
right right
Urgent Care Urgent right like if I had a
doorknob but it was sturdy
I'd be having crazy thoughts help right
right right Suicide Hotline in person
right
are you gonna use those I don't know I
don't have anyone to use them with at
the moment but I'll I'll when booty
calls next time booty calls I will
answer with my DTF imagine just hooking
up with a guy and being like one second
let me take this pill real quick let me
see that shit it actually looks really
cool it's like a cool capsule hold on I
don't know if I can open it
huh
are you about to take it right now
dude I don't know why I can't open it
let me ask you are you going to Austin
anytime soon I feel like I am sometimes
I feel like you're flirting with the
idea of why don't you go I'm going the
first week of June are you going the
first week of June March I mean I'm
going in May oh you're going soon you're
gonna go do Mothership yeah I think so
I'ma try to go see what where are you
gonna stay see what they're talking
about I feel like you're going to want
to stay there
I think I am too but am I I mean can you
just stay for a couple months can you
just split your time I could I do like a
I do like I'm honestly low-key I'm
probably do like three two or three
weeks out there nothing crazy because
you know like I can't like I said before
like I can even do a month out there
before Texas summer you're gonna be like
what Leaf it's it's intense also there's
a serial killer in in Texas okay so I'm
on stage of the comedy Mothership oh
shit I make some joke about being
murdered okay this is a black capsule oh
yeah oh yeah that's sweet that's right
that's for your black would it costs
ominous shit dad
um so I'm in Texas and I make some joke
about getting murdered or being murdered
or something and the audience gets like
really quiet like why am I bombing what
and I'm like what is someone getting
murdered like you know when you like
walk go into a city and you make a joke
and like that shit's going on in the
city oh yeah you're like because there
was just a student that was sleeping
with a professor and it gets awkward and
they're like what happened and they're
like our football coach just raped a
student you're like okay well I could
how the fuck would I have known that so
I'm in Austin on stage I say some joke
about being murdered everyone gets
awkward as shit I'm like what
and they're like there's a serial killer
on the loose in Austin
and I was like damn what do you mean
Rogan
and he comic he doesn't like that comes
in right
and I'm like what do you mean there's a
serial killer like walk me through this
and they're like oh there's a bridge and
the serial killer Waits and pushes men
off the bridge it's only men eight men
have been pushed off this bridge at like
two in the morning where's this bridge
it's like downtown Austin and I was like
let's just chill for a second so what
are the chances that the headline is
serial killer
gently nudges men off of a bridge at two
in the morning like that bitch ass
serial killer who's just like you know
or y'all are such raging alcoholics that
you're just stumbling into the room like
it right if you've been Austin at 1am
it's fucking Zombieland dude it is like
it is p people in wheelchair I saw a guy
in a wheelchair at two in the morning
stand up and Sprint out of his
wheelchair like it was people are
getting their powers back it's my kind
of homeless they're drinking something
last time I was there there were two
bars on the street that that Mothership
was on playing
this shit is bananas
that's drugs yeah that is a level of
drugs that is like so I was like they're
they're it's like Bourbon Street yeah
yeah you know but serial killer there's
apparently they're really spooked about
the serial killer they're like it's only
men the bridge Pusher walk it yeah it's
like are you trying to try to push
someone they'll grab someone would agree
he don't he put like like how do you
push somebody off a bridge is he picking
them up and then throwing them I'm
saying you can't just put like I mean
maybe and they're like they're not
finding any Foul Play
but it's like if you walk past it I'm
like I would trip over the shit and fall
like sober during the day like this is
so dangerous this show is sponsored by
betterhelp it's so easy to get caught up
in what everybody else needs from you
and never take a moment to think about
what you need from yourself but when we
spend all of our time giving gosh this
is like even reading this better health
copy makes me realize I need to maybe
double up on the better help sessions it
on the teleprompter it says we spend all
our time giving and I saw the word
grieving and
we spend all of our time grieving it can
leave us
therapy can give you the tools to find
more balance in your life so you can
keep supporting others without leaving
yourself behind
um I uh actually just started uh in
addition to the therapy I'm doing on my
own uh couples therapy with my sister
and I don't think we should call it that
that's a little incesty family there is
family therapy it's like a total miracle
I feel like if I'd done this with a man
I'd have I'd be Octomom
so thank God better help did not exist
until now if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
discover your potential with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com Whitney today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com Whitney I just
want to see if I could do that and I
could tell me about your special oh man
it's called rotten Luther King Jr it was
directed by Andrew thimulus he uh
produces the Bill Burr podcast and um I
filmed it oh so he's the one that just
sits there by Bill like fights with his
uh computer charger for 30 minutes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so the man has patience yeah and uh we
filmed it at Panama Pacific Park what
made you decide to shoot it outside was
that a panda like post-pandemic decision
yeah yeah I was no no I was in pan yeah
I um I did like a show there in the
pandemic and I was like oh I like these
lives it'd be dealt with this shit was
filled up and then so I said hey memory
shooting a special outside on some
Charlie Barnett shit or whatever turning
it on and watching you be outside in
this round it was almost like a Grecian
theater like you know it you know what
it felt like it
it made me realize how like when I watch
a special how claustrophobic I feel and
how I like worry about the audience
being like trapped yeah it felt so good
to just be like this is a consensual
show yeah they can literally leave
whenever they want and it just felt so
like I don't know it was just like so
fun to watch it was made so differently
than any other special I'd ever seen
yeah we're just a minute to like a gang
of film festivals and shit too so I
don't I think that more people should be
swimming would you remember when Kevin
Hart released one of his specials in
theaters and it did great I don't know
why more of us don't do that I was
talking to IMAX about the you know
number one requested thing from in IMAX
theaters which I guess
um but uh is comedy yeah yeah it is
weird that we like release them on our
fucking phones now yep I submit it to
like at least seven film festivals so I
hope it gets one tomorrow yeah and so
like yeah it was real fun I'm just glad
are there at comedy festivals are there
film like yeah yeah it's a New York
Comedy Festival have like a specials
I I don't know I submitted mine to the
LA comedy film festival like the LA
comedy film festival but they never ever
but nobody ever submits like stand-up
comedy that's so smart so I'm like send
it there it looks theatrical that's so
smart you know so yeah so that and a
bunch of other shit now it was real fun
to do I'm glad that I got to do it my
way the first time and then now you have
a whole new
or that you're touring with uh then I'm
fucking around with yeah yeah do you
feel like there's anything right now
that like like with you know people like
being a comedian must be so hot either
you can't say anything is there anything
that you feel like you can't say I don't
be I like I don't whenever people saying
that I don't listen to that shit I'm
like free it's it's actually like I kind
of think this is the best time since
I've done comedy it's like there's
eggshells on the ground again there's
tension like it's actually more fun
people would be like oh cancel closer
I'm like that shit ain't real look I'm
gonna say this dude cancel me it's like
I'll God forbid I sell out four shows
God forbid I started selling out Arenas
oh God like that shit ain't like do
whatever the fuck you want to do that's
who cares yeah because and then what
what did you think because I know you
came to the you did you come to both of
us you came to the roast of my roasts
came to your rose and I was holding uh
I'm here to fuck uh Whitney poster uh
which I'm so glad that I did I almost I
was like I don't know her personality is
she gonna get mad at seeing this shit do
you think I was like well I was like had
to yell at the crowd the whole night
yeah so I was like oh man I said you
know so I was over here like
dude I'm telling you like it's just like
I made a little bit of mistake in the in
shooting the things I want to shoot at
The Comedy Store I want to only use our
Comics like real Comics not like random
celebrities or people that think they're
Comics or like Instagram fucking
whatever you would say you're a boss
bitch bag what do you mean yo Boss Bitch
bag like he was in your bag I mean he
was in your using a boss bitch mode well
you got a fucking Wrangle like a taping
is not a game you have to Twitter you
can killing that shit though you really
gonna Wrangle the fuck out of people and
make people shut up and listen you know
what I'm saying I should I mean it's
just guys we're moving into the theater
right now everybody everybody
he moved him over there with the red
shirt
we're going into the theater and it
should be having like this this green
vanity popping her head leave it alone
leave this bitch I'm like all right man
you in the restaurant then go over there
like they have to
yeah fucking sucks because I was like
you don't understand okay so I was like
let's do this invite only so make sure
it's comics and then it was only fans
Talent too but the problem with only
fans Talent are like hot girls it's like
these are the girls that believe the
Like rules don't apply to them yeah
these are the girls that like I don't
wait in lines and like like when they
get on planes the Pilot's like do you
want to see the cockpit like it's like
I'm glad that you do that though but
like they're they're in cowboy house
walking through camera angle like I
literally want to like edit together
just all of the camera angles on
people's like singles on their amazing
jokes where some fucking girl was
walking through with a cowboy hat
blocking the shot and I'm like this is a
taping what first of all why are you all
on drugs second why are all because you
can't go to the bathroom for an hour you
know you can't and I told them go to the
bathroom now and I don't know if they're
all doing blow or if they have UTIs or
what of course all of it but they're
getting up to go and I'm like what are
you do what did I just say is it because
I'm a girl is it because I just you
don't respect Comics like dude like what
is that there you go
yeah yeah I'm like is this fentanyl is
this Adderall is this mushrooms like I
don't know what drug this is but it's
five o'clock on a Sunday what the fuck
are you guys like
I don't know but you're an amazing
Wrangler I think it has something to do
those horses and you just being ever
control animals it was just like it was
the most now you got to do paid when we
do this again it has to be you have to
pay like five dollars again if people
don't pay they don't think it's a value
facts yeah yeah especially only fans
people and it's also like I wanted to
make it so the audience you would see
them and everything felt really like
like um you know I just want to feel
very populated and chaotic and like wild
and like so that shit came out real good
though you think like yeah it was some
really good shit I haven't seen yours
yet but like it was really good who's
this who's this next uh I don't know we
I only did two they basically only fans
came to me and they were like here's a
budget to make two 15-minute pieces of
content for only fans TV and I was like
I don't know how to make something for
15 minutes like I don't know what that
is and I was like how about two hour
roasts that's the only thing that I feel
like makes sense yeah you know like
great writers and shit too like I I
really like that it was all Comics like
real Comics like people that deserve to
be roast in their own right yeah and
then um we shot the writer's room too
because I wanted to be able to like have
a little like behind the scenes like
yeah that's for social media so that all
the comics like you do goodbye people I
like that I mean do you think like I
don't know I think that
future roast like you can't just say
let's do four more you have to be like
you have to find the person to do it
like you know yeah it's like if
Chappelle or Kevin Hart because it also
has to be someone that's like a good
person yeah you can't roast a bad person
yeah that's awkward yeah and like the
idea is that you're like celebrating
them and giving them an opportunity to
like you know atone for their sins and
it's really a celebration at the end of
the day yeah it has to be someone
beloved like RuPaul would be amazing
yeah Chappelle would be amazing but if
you don't have something to do it you
can't just find some like like that's
what I feel like The Comedy Central
roast is like they did one every year
and it wasn't about like like let's say
Willie Nelson and then Willie Nelson
would drop out and they'd be like well
let's do
Corey Haim and you're like no just don't
do it yeah there's got to be someone
that it makes sense yeah before so yeah
so I don't really know like I think
we'll do more but I think it has to be
like Talent contingent yeah well that's
some good shit you're doing over there
you know I like it I like showing up to
him and shit I think we'll start doing
specials on only fans I think they start
syndicating specials I think they'll
start licensing them on the ones off
YouTube because a lot of the ones on
YouTube are getting demonetized or taken
out of the algorithm if you say certain
shit oh yeah man I mean I only have 11
000 views that means it got taken out of
the album I'm like damn have you gotten
any money from them no not not a dime
but it was fun to shoot yeah I think
that that it's gonna go many other
places yeah like you own it like the
best thing because you think about all
the people that are so big right now
they didn't get deals with Hollywood 15
years ago Sebastian Joe Coy Gabriel
Iglesias they were forced to because
they didn't have a choice make their own
specials and pay for them themselves and
then they ended up later having the last
laugh sorry for the pun because all my
specials are owned by Comedy Central
Viacom I can't get them I can't put them
on my social media because I don't own
them yeah whereas like Joe Coy and
Sebastian and uh uh Gabriel Iglesias and
stuff they own their shit so they could
sell it to Amazon and Showtime they own
their audio they can put it on Spotify
whatever so it's just like owning it
like this is just the first leg of the
life of that special facts you can
license it to Amazon you can put it on
all kinds of shit you can cut it up and
put it on your social and like yeah yeah
that was cool I'm just glad that I got
the first one out of the way because it
took me so long to like be like all
right we're doing it now because I
usually only put our albums and shit or
whatever I was just infatuated with just
doing albums I liked albums and shit
like you're so physical though I just
feel like it's like half of I wanted to
be respected as a writer you know what
I'm saying so like when you hear his
jokes or whatever they're you know you
know oh man it's funny or whatever so I
just want to be respected as a writer
like yo before I came out and did all
this physical shit you know I'm saying I
want to be like no no but if you go back
my nigga great you know like that's
that's someone who's such a good
performer that they like I feel like I
had the opposite where I would get off
stage and people be like you are such a
good writer yeah which is like okay I'm
not a good performer you know what I
mean it's kind of like I don't even
understand that shit at first like when
people were like oh okay yeah or when
people be like oh you're a good writer
and I'm like what does that even mean
I'm like even like well are you saying
that I can say funny things like that's
what you're saying yeah I can say funny
things I'm like say that because this
writing I'm like I don't know no one
knows what to fucking say when you come
outside no one's ever nailed it it's
always like you really look like you
were having fun up there yeah yeah right
right that's fucked up what it's like
yeah you come off stage your friend is
like I could never do that like I know
you work at the post office
like or you come upstairs like so what
are you working on yeah yeah yeah like
that
um you just saw it yeah like huh you
didn't see what I rolled around around
it's just like Jesus man um but also I
kind of want to bring back the half hour
oh yeah yeah a lot of times you're like
I got two or three things that make
sense for a half hour if I keep doing
this shit for another six months it's
gonna get stale it's gonna feel
irrelevant where would you put the half
hour only fans yes only fans TV yo facts
yup I like that you could shoot four
half hours in a night at The Comedy
Store you could do two half hours a year
and even stuff that you're like I'm not
gonna put this in an hour special like
about you know personal shit that's
Evergreen but like something that's
about something now yeah six months
there's too many funny people out there
to look on Twitter like dude the people
that work in fucking customer service
that insurance companies are making
these memes that are funny all the memes
are not made by comedians yeah they're
made by normal people like this bitch at
my job did this the statistically
funniest people in the world can me are
sending memes to each other that no
comedians made no no no people are funny
so we gotta now change the way that we
you know I think going back to this like
waiting a year to put your shit I'm like
I'm sick of this material I don't even
want to do this shit anymore yep yep yep
or someone else got to a version of of
it like someone tweeted like ah like
someone is we're not the only people
that think this shit you know it's like
the only people with the fucking balls
to do it on stage so there's times
they'll have a take and you're like such
an original take and then you flesh it
out and then you see a meme that's
basically and you're like ah why because
part of the reason that when you go out
and you have this original take on
something people go oh yeah I've
actually thought of that before hey did
you see that thing I sent you about the
uh about the Siamese twins sharing one
vagina but they got one boyfriend
did you see that shit
I wanna fuck there's no way I missed
that I want the other one no vagina I
want that no no they're both sharing a
vagina but I want the other one
the one the one I don't but because she
said that only one of us have a
boyfriend
when did you say you sent this to me I
sent that shit to you in the group text
with him okay this was okay oh you had
to look back
sure I get sued yeah when Pat's ready to
to Cash Out Hold on you didn't see that
shit no
oh we're conjoined twins and share a
vagina but only one of us has a
boyfriend yeah and I need a bit of other
dude
ah is that ins count as incest if
they've conjointed their 22 year old
Lupita and Carmen I love this Lupita and
Carmen I love that when conjoined twins
were born the parents were like we
picked the names
one name one pussy I mean that like why
this is Carmen and this is a little bit
nodded they're both fucking
earthworm just name them one something
that works is one name
you know what I mean Marianne yeah yeah
like just make it a hyphenated name have
you ever seen one in real life a
conjoined twin I haven't yeah have you
no I have not where would you say that
not up close the air and space museum
where are they these days it used to be
if you had some kind of shit like that
you would go to the circus and make
money
the bearded lady getting bread she got
moment of everybody she live in a house
like this
the bearded lady the girl you dm'd on
Bumble with the heavy hands they've
never tried to have a surgery that would
separate them as it could be fatal how
do you know slice the pussy in half I
don't know I don't know dicks
porn
they had physical therapy to learn how
to sit up and work their legs how did
the boyfriend get
to no one without the other
put like a little sheet over there
like how does you know what I mean like
how do you fall in love with a conjoined
twin I don't know you ruined my life
sending me this I never tried to hide
the fact that I'm a conjoined twin yeah
yeah okay
I thought you were a big ass spider like
damn immediately you really have sex and
get a finger in your ass if it's I could
not like when I tried one you can't even
reach it I threw out my shoulder
sometimes I feel bad because I want to
spend so much time with Danielle so we
try to come up with compromises like
Lupita will choose where we go out to
dinner what activity we're gonna do
I hate this do they have two hearts them
hoes need to just realize that they
confused just like everybody else one of
the conjoined twins has a nose ring
let me see that's that's the one I want
she the freak
I like the other one one's a virgin and
one's a heart
but also if one has an orgasm do they
both have it
oh hey did you know that one of them's
faking it like
yeah like
we're faking it I heard I heard you last
night
just like ah another one's like what are
you doing ah did you know that ducks
have have different passages to their
pussies and only one is correct so they
so they can't so they can prevent uh
male rape male duck rape
oh you got dust downstairs
you about to start watching the
motherfuckers close Leon wait so they
have such they have a fake ton a fake
female ducks have many passages but uh
in in their pussies but only one is the
real hole
because they want to prevent Mel we have
a couple of those too though I feel like
we have a couple y'all got a pee hole a
booty hole and it's a pussy yeah but I
feel like there's a lot of just mushy
areas that like I feel
like guys are always surprised at how
far back the vagina hole is yo it's
shocking I used to fucking chick who was
like okay you couldn't go you couldn't
like you couldn't go past a certain
amount or whatever or else you're like
your dick would be like this a wall
it'd be like shit no no I'm talking
about I'm in the pussy or whatever and
it's like you couldn't go like she had
like a little like you know how pussy
like you can put all your dick in or
whatever usually or whatever yeah like
this like this chick here it just
stopped like right here and it's like
what the fuck is this is that a good
thing I don't know but it's like I don't
know that's cancer yeah she had a tumor
oh you were fucking a tumor well I tried
to knock that shit off because I'm a
good person that was a baby oh
that's crazy I was told I do have a
tilted uterus what's that mean so I
think I have it you just
I know like like what that means you're
trying to be like sympathetic I haven't
tilted you don't see what what does that
mean like what that mean like like it I
don't know it tilts forward so that I
think there's a little bit of that
for real yeah but I put a tampon in it
like kind of comes back out for real
man you know when you like all female
commas got problems
is this normal I mean that's basically
what it's not two problems no I just
think that like I had got health care
I'm sure most most people just don't
have Healthcare they don't know what the
fuck's going on damn that's crazy as
soon as I got Healthcare they're like
you have this and this and this and I'm
like sorry it's got a tilt the uterus or
whatever I had a chick who had like one
um who had like one what's the two
things y'all got she had one of them
not in the pussy ovaries yeah she had
one ovary she had one ovary uh what that
mean
how old was she oh she's like 42. yeah
she might have had one explode or was
born without one a picture I don't know
what happened you don't ask a lot of
questions too nah I just be trying to
like it is tricky because girl I you're
making me realize I don't want to judge
anyone how guys don't want to know your
like vaginal broken I think on some
level we think she's like I only went
over it like I think the subtext was
like don't worry I won't get pregnant
and you're like oh yeah Dad's reading
that's what that's what she did say she
was like well you can eat me pregnant or
some shit like there is hard or whatever
I only have one over it yeah
some guy guys fucked the other one to a
pulp yeah squirt it that was fun
um
Square are you like bummed
offended no no no no but squirt I mean
squirting is fun you know when you said
when it happens and shit like oh I did
that if it's at your house maybe yeah I
mean just if you you just you got a
cleaner lady you just clean it shouldn't
be like Dexter and I have to put a tarp
down man you soft are you doing stand-up
tonight yeah I got 10 30 at the comedy
store but I I can talk on this podcast
forever forever this is like Pat aren't
I being different with him
yeah this is this is a good one oh bro
yeah we just talk and how long are these
podcasts usually
like when you release them that's a
great question are you gonna release it
I know four hour podcast anywhere from
uh one to seven hours yeah yeah if we we
cross the time space continue hey I like
that shit yeah yeah I don't but it's
also like to me I'm like
when people come all the way out here I
come I came all the way up here and I
only have people on that I like that I
actually want to hang out with
yeah you know what I thought you'd be oh
for someone to tune into a podcast and
be like this is too long like oh I'm
sorry two people just like like they're
all if they're 10 minutes they're too
long yeah yeah that's fine I cast or not
like like the people that do they're
driving trucks they're at work like
you're looking to kill time you're right
give me another shot please don't take
it you can take this honey badger I'm
not taking it honey pot I can't ride in
my fucking what Cosby used to to have
you
who is the first comedian you saw where
you were like Martin Lawrence ah Martin
Lawrence uh that's the first Community I
ever saw in my fucking life and I was
like I was like whatever the fuck that
is
wait I got I gotta hit that I can't and
then did you watch the sitcom yeah
did I watch the sick go back and watch
it now that okay so it's still funny
Martin is the reason I made a sitcom in
the first place like uh even though it's
weird because most brilliant comedians
watching them deterred me from doing
comedy because I was like oh I'll never
be that good you know what's the point
of trying like they didn't inspire me
um but watching the sitcom I just was
like I want to be
doing whatever the fuck that is I mean
there is do you remember because also it
started to get super third uh breaking
the I'm sorry for fourth wall in I think
it was season three when he had that
baby well do you remember when at the
end he jumped out of the window and then
everyone in the crew ran and jumped out
the window after him
the sky the camera guy and you saw the
whole crew follow him out the way
the one that I've made a TV show knowing
that he ran from a scene that he was in
two minutes later was dressed as
Shanaynay fully in that character
Martin's a god Martin's a fucking God I
re-watched the whole fucking show every
season over the pandemic just to watch
the other characters who aren't Martin
try to not laugh yep yep there's nothing
more fun than watching everyone be like
yeah the actors are cracking up yep yep
the whole energy in that motherfucker I
I I I I I I want to do something not
like that but just as like like some
sort of signal you have that electricity
you do have that lightning in a bottle
can't be top
can't have an actor do it like you've
got that I want to show like that
physical it don't got to be that but
something like that physical where it's
just like man we just fucking around
like and by the way it's just funny it's
funny I mean also the braver I mean the
way that Martin in fucking Pam would go
at it
was so funny and honestly like today but
you can't make fun to me it always felt
I mean this word is so tricky but like
feminist to be like oh she's an equal
he'll go at her too and he always made
it so she had come back that were just
as fine you never felt sorry for Pam
yeah and then and then sometimes
sometimes Martin will let her win like
oh all right anyway so yeah let's let
her win you know he could have kept
going but let her win yeah and it was
always like to her tracks and her it was
always like B to b or some type nobody
knew what kind of animal Pam was like it
was like the cage yeah she was always
coming from a cage zoo or something but
it was so sad I know how hard it is for
you trying to kill a family member like
when they had to fight that rat like
damn when do you remember when he worked
at the was it the DMV when he was a
janitor at the DMV yeah yeah and he got
his check and he's like my salmon is
said yeah like he's just like he made
comedy where there was none you know
what I like I like uh when he played
dragonfly Jones remember him suicide
pool no that one but like when he would
just when he would get hit and then he
would do extra shit like like to like
you know I'm saying like uh you hit him
but he was just exaggerate how bad they
hit her or whatever he'd do extra shit
he'll like uh like when he was fighting
the karate dude
he called 9-1-1 on the ATM machine like
like little shit like that I'm like oh
my God
it was just but also and then I also met
dork about the history of it because the
more you know about the history of
Martin the more you know you can
appreciate his genius like by season two
the the actual actress that played Gina
and him had a falling and then they
wouldn't be in scenes together she
wouldn't so they were in different
scenes remember you can see Gina going
to work and then he was going to the
radio station and they weren't really in
scenes together but like the time you
didn't really know that but it they made
it work by season three you know they
talked about it he was kind of
struggling with like some substance
abuse issues and you would see that that
by season three it was like these one
takes they weren't using singles they
weren't using two shots and in a lot of
the shots he'd be doing whatever genius
improv and he would go out of frame and
come back in like it was clear that like
yeah they were only fucking the show up
it looked like he would only do one take
or maybe he was whatever was going on
man somebody told me that like uh
somebody told me that like when they
would go there live and she's at Martin
beat running all in the in the uh in the
um in the stands and shit with the fans
and like all that shit like doing all
kinds of shit I'm like oh but can I tell
you that's like what I fucking meant
like I mean back to and I think he
wanted to bring this up and I probably
cut I think I cut you off which on brand
is is five but being a try hard yeah
like you I look it's com some comic say
and they're just like doing the lace and
I'm leaning against a brick wall and I'm
talking about my depression and it's
like
if you don't need this so badly that
you're running up and down in the stands
and doing backflips like get out of our
way I should be trying to have the most
fun possible and people want to watch
people having fun thank you thank you
and then people want to leave going hey
remember what we saw some guy his name
uh this comic Maurice King a long time
ago he told me he said hey man listen
the audience comes to see some crazy
shit come to see I want to come and hear
some crazy shit to see delusional
confidence to live vicariously why do
you look like you're waiting for the bus
I can see that driving down the street
you know and I think there's this like
too cool for school comedian thing where
they're kind of just like leaning and
stole and they're like what else is
happening it's like people paid money
yep and then sometimes and I always I
always have to get on uh sometimes I
have to get on myself uh about this
which I don't which I don't I don't care
about like how I look on stage or
whatever like as far as like trying to
like look I'm trying to like look cute
or whatever I say it because every time
I lead a house everything you ain't come
here to be cute you know what I'm saying
you'll see you you ain't come here to be
cute this isn't that it's in the beauty
pageant you know like well you're cute
yeah thank you but I'm like you didn't
come here yeah but I'm like you didn't
come here today do you mean like when
you get dressed you're like conscious of
like you know yeah I say I say I don't
get fuck with you when you go up there
and before you go out there and be good
first little clown on me during the
pandemic for having blue hair and pink
hair and all that shit but like I gotta
be honest with you when I think of my
like influences as a stand-up you know
it wasn't just stand-up comics because I
didn't have access to that super yeah
like um John Ritter from Three's Company
he's FL doing fashion Ritter couches
Problem Child have you what yeah
yeah Problem Child I don't what's that
you never said he did no the hit movie
yo do you remember Problem Child I don't
know if I do what fucking what's my man
name um
Gilbert Godfrey uh yeah yeah he was all
up in it you gotta watch that shit well
I don't know if you appreciate it now do
you have you ever seen the John Ritter
versus a hammock
yeah this he's the most genius
who because going into this you're like
oh I know what he's gonna do and you do
and it's still
so genius
he's just trying to get in a hammock
40 year old man facts again
trying to get in the hammock
the struggle is so he is committed so
hard in my recent Jonathan winter shit
you ever see Jonathan Winters but uh
like yes and no I don't know it Jonathan
Winters like what he would he would take
a St he would take a stick or whatever
and he would only improv with that stick
or whatever and but he would he would
make it a bunch of different things in
like three minutes whatever Rob Williams
was well that was his hero and he was
really good at shit like that oh I need
to study up on that yeah yeah but it was
just like and then uh John de Winters
played a baseball guy or whatever who he
did three minutes as a baseball guy
whatever but like just him I forgot what
show it was like the stick would steal
his own hat and walk away with it yeah
so was it choreographed or improvised he
was improvised yep because also hey do
11 funny things with that shit or
whatever right right I need to like
really like brush up on some inspiration
for like like crowd Pleasers there's
like people a lot of people look down at
Comics rather look down on like crowd
Pleasers type shit you know I mean
you're like but it's pleasing the crowd
Maron big fan but why am I trying to
make you like me while I'm on stage like
if the the harder I try the less
comedians are gonna fucking groan but
like I'm not here to entertain you
you're not buying tickets and I think
sometimes we get so Twisted in trying to
get our heroes to like us or the comics
in the back of the room because we grew
up that way we're we're the comment
where the comments we were coming up we
were given opportunity oh you you do if
I find you funny you can get on my show
whatever sudden we but also Comics
aren't supposed to be cool yeah you know
what I'm saying we're like the Clinton
it can be like dice play was cool but
it's cool to make people laugh because
that's cool but if you're like fuck you
guys like I'm just I have mono and Lyme
disease and uh this is like all I'm
gonna I'm gonna read off a pad of paper
like Lyme disease what is that it's this
thing
don't get me started on all the rich
white people that have lime they go to
The Hamptons and they get Lyme disease
it's from a tick it's just fucking it's
just Darwinism oh they're getting fucked
up kill rich people just so you know I'm
very Pro tick
um they literally literally eat the
ranch they don't threaten it they
fucking do it but my Inspirations like I
was like I didn't know I wanted to be a
stand-up comedian I knew I wanted to be
an Entertainer because I knew what
entertainment did for me like I
literally I would watch fucking Pauly
Shore on MTV fucking jams like I would
watch I was like entertainment saved me
Ambition saved me as future girl but
like it saved me and one of my main
Inspirations and I remember this during
the pandemic because I was like how are
you an Entertainer if you can't go out
and entertain like we're in front of our
phones and our like Zoom shows I don't
know how to do this like I if I don't
get that sound right away like I'm like
the Zoom shows it was like we worked so
hard to get perfect timing and then
there's a delay yeah on Zoom shows and
you're kind of like this is I'm worried
this makes me worse
one of my main Inspirations was Dennis
Robin okay I was obsessed with Dennis
Rodman because I played basketball
really seriously so I was already
obsessed with him because it was like I
was never going to be the best uh uh
offense shooting I would like I knew I
was never the fastest I was never the
quickest I was never the most confident
but if you pass me the ball I would
always make it yeah I was like I'm just
I'm never gonna miss I'm always the
person when there's a technical foul
they're gonna call me I'm gonna be great
under pressure and I'm never gonna miss
a shot yeah but everything else like
and then uh watching Dennis Rodman going
he has the most thankless job right but
he's doing like you know a lot but
rebounding is the most important job but
it's kind of the most thankless and he
was like I'm gonna be entertaining
as I'm gonna my hair is going to be blue
I'm gonna wear wedding dress I'm gonna
have a nose ring like he was just an
Entertainer he knew yeah
he wasn't gonna be like I'm gonna be the
coolest person here he's like I as I'm
running down the court you're only
looking at me yeah you know and I
remember just being like Dennis Rodman
like that he just knew how to put on a
show and then when the pandemic came
like yeah I kind of did it also because
my hair artist was like didn't have any
money was losing health insurance and it
was like but then I was like yeah how
can I be entertaining just sit fucking
sitting in my house yeah and it's not
about being liked it's about being
entertaining or people thinking you're
cool or together who cares keep them
guessing like just fucking entertainment
just do shit yeah I'm using him to sit
here with brown hair like a fucking
arrogant
part like you know what I mean just
scrolling through Instagram in a fucking
pandemic I'm Gonna Give You Blue Hair
you know
Courtney Love
chaos yep yeah yeah
I had it I didn't mind when you're doing
that I was like cool
you know what my mistake was about that
is that I didn't realize that if you
bleach your hair and diet you have to
condition it
crush it and I just Let It Go full
crackhead Annie the thing yeah the thing
was people was just like people because
like when you was when he was doing that
shit people already just saw you as one
thing so then when you started doing
that people were like well she's going
crazy she's not the it's not the woman
empowerment person anymore she's dying
her hair blue she's she's having you
know whatever the fuck whatever it's
like bitch I just painted my hair blue
yeah like or like oh remember how we
used to always clown her for working too
hard now she's having fun and like
you're gonna you hate me either way but
it's also like like you know I I that is
it was wild it was wild what's a lot
about painting a motherfucking hair blue
like it was like that's not even my hair
when they're like Whitney which dyed her
hair blue she's going crazy now I I went
crazy when I was keeping it brown to try
to get Hollywood producers to like me do
I mean like so I could get that's when I
went crazy when I was like God man got
to keep it this brown color so I can get
cash as the girl next door and a Chuck
Lori's sitcom thanks that's that's crazy
facts to be to be financially solvent
have freedom be creative and not be able
to do reckless fun shit
yeah to deprive yourself of that that's
crazy yeah that's why we got into comedy
so I can um I I used to say this shit
all the time before I um before I got
into comedy because I was like a theater
major and I had dropped out or whatever
but I used to always tell my I just I
remember going to The Comedy Store one
day and just watching Everybody after
coming from school and I would just be
watching everybody was sitting in the
back and I'm like Jamar this is nothing
but theater bro and I said I said the
monologue yeah I say you could actually
go through and do whatever the fuck you
want to do you know I'm saying like
people don't say shit but I'm like
you're the fuck you want to do but I
would say when someone's like if you
come from theater program and someone's
like I'm nervous to stand up well you
know how to act right right act like you
can do stand-ups just act like you're
not nervous and that's when I cracked it
because I studied as an actress then I
was like I can't stand up I'm scared I'm
like when I just like I'm not scared
yeah and I would just go up and be like
I'm the fucking shit I know how to do
this then I go off stage
like you know and then fake it till you
make it yeah that's all like I just had
to act like I wasn't scared I had to act
like the comics in the hallway didn't
scare me I had to act like I had more
money I had to act like I was making it
when I wasn't thanks and then and then
there's so like and I feel like with
comedy
I had this delusional Instinct where I
was like okay everyone's kind of trying
to do this like what if I set my goals
so impossibly high there's no
competition up there yeah because I was
like how do I eliminate all this
competition yeah and I was like why
don't I go like oh I'm gonna get a
special in four years yeah and then I
was like shit I'm gonna get a special in
four years yeah and I just started
acting like it was actually gonna happen
and then acting accordingly I was like I
gotta get my shit together damn man that
shit really worked that's that that
secret shit the scene try like try it
like just give your like our act like
the goal is already here you got to be
who you who the fuck you think you are
you know if my dog takes that and starts
humping everything in my house one of
them's red and one of them's black I
know this feels like when you're gonna
take first this is a Black Mirror
episode that I wouldn't be able to get
whatever happened to Black Mirror the
new a new season is coming out the
American version is just the English
version was Next Level
it was pretty scary like kind of sort of
like it was really scary the English
version
much better than American TV but like
Black Mirror it was like
that was like the first episode of Black
Mirror the original is wild crocodile
and uh uh what was the one that was
white bear
what how many seasons do they got right
now I think it's on the it's on the I
think they did two seasons two or three
seasons in the English version then the
American version I think their third
season the American version is out I
just saw it oh I just saw it on like
Instagram and I was like oh nice oh okay
I'm into it I'm into those like
Anthology series thing that fox show I
did was an anthology it was like one up
I was like one episode every actor did a
different episode black mirrors are just
getting scary because it was it felt
real it felt like in the music that they
would play behind it I'm like ah I if
you tore enough in a man I don't know
I'm kind of most people don't let me ask
you this I was just in fucking Duluth
and there was hardly any Wi-Fi sorry Pat
let me ask you this are you are you one
of those girls who are into like uh who
are in like murder documentaries do you
like those I'm not I feel like a lot of
people talk about it because they think
it's like cute to be in a murder
documentary it's like ironic or
something I don't
I'm not like I don't like get off on I
like when it's
um uh adapted for television like the
wondery documentaries Dr Death the uh
what was her name Amanda Pete her
performance in the fuck uh the woman
that killed the guy in La Jolla it was
Christian Slater Pat Uh Debbie Broderick
the Debbie so like I listened dirty John
but but what was the one with um there
was one with Connie Britton it was about
the guy that pretended to be an
anesthesiologist and like
and then tried to that was on Instagram
no who's that are you gonna see him what
this is it's his kid it's his kid he's
like probably like 18 or whatever he
pretending to be a doctor or whatever
and he and they put him in jail he was
like 18. but how did he get away with
pretending to be a doctor it feels like
he just put on a suit yeah but I feel
like the patients were if you
see this but but anyway but yeah what
was the name of the wondery show that
was the adaptation of it that was Amanda
Pete and Christian Slater her
performances
uh chef's kiss she is so incredible so I
like to watch it to like learn about it
and then watch the theatrical yeah
oh bunny by the way he's got he went to
Spencer's Gifts and got the uh okay
Florida teenager Fusion proven
pretending to be a doctor has been
indicted well laughter is the best
medicine we're the real doctors you guys
um oh dirty John was the name of the
series and there was like a couple
installments her performance in this is
fucking unreal what's his name it was
arrested okay the LA his last name is
Robinson hey pull up pull up the fake
black doctor
I I mean by the way he tried to buy a
Lexus using fake earrings
he was all fucking he remains jailed
love Robinson was arrested in Florida in
February after officials said he was
practicing medicine without license well
how did he get all the fucking stuff I
guess it's pretty easy to get fentanyl
at this point he allegedly stole 35 000
from a patient well wow
he's kind of handsome that's my type I
like I like oh he's a fake doctor I like
an alien his name is Malachi that's my
middle name hola is it hold up hold it
hold it how did oh after he contacted
the customers for payment Malachi love
Robin it seems like such a
so excited about the idea of having a
black doctor that they just go like he
looks like a kiss
yeah but
he went after old people that were uh
probably obtained money under false
pretense identity theft and forgery but
by the way this is very ambitious I kind
of respect this I'm always here for some
siblings between someone that pretends
to be a doctor and someone that's a
doctor according to the court
documentary by the way they say now that
every doctor that graduates from Medical
School within 14 months their medical
degree will be obsolete because of how
fast technology is changing in medical
research so
he might not know that much less than
the average licensed doctor
I mean who needs a doctor when you got
WebMD and Urgent he's like defined
doctor
um doctors get shit where he could work
for Kaiser Permanente
he'd probably be better than half of the
fucking people there
hmm who did this art for Martin Luther
King Jr uh Ryan e belt it's so pretty
yeah he's cool he does a lot of kill
Tony shit Leon next shit dropping my
next special yeah you working on it now
yeah it's like it's
it's kind of want to do it as a half
hour because it's I'm kind of only
talking about the trans stuff drag queen
like it feels like it needs to be a half
hour yeah because it's like for me when
I do specials for some reason I kind of
have one theme yeah I feel like because
I hate Segways I don't like being like
and here's my Facebook joke and here's
my health insurance joke and here's my
relation you know what I mean I like for
it all to kind of feel like one thing
yeah after I did the special about sex
robots and it was like only about that
and with the sex robot coming out of the
end I just loved how like
it was about like one thing yeah so I
kind of want to just do that and not
worry about the length and just worry
about the content and then whatever
length is the length is because you're
like God I have to read 60 minutes and
you're like I have a brilliant or in my
head or a great 52. yeah and I'm gonna
add some story that doesn't fit her
jokes that don't fit just to get to 61
for 61 minutes like I just kind of like
I think that especially in a time where
everybody's just putting up dirty
however much time they fucking feel they
got but also a lot of specials like a
lot of people don't it should be as long
as it is good or as long as it is ready
it's like why can't I mean Chappelle
does it help out at a 15 minute special
and it'll put an hour 20 and then you
have to put out 30. like the content
should dictate the length you shouldn't
go here you have to do an hour
why don't I do a great 30 minutes in
January and a great 30 minutes in July
yeah yeah yeah and like and like comedy
is like it's getting towards I mean it's
getting to that way whereas like people
isn't Rogan or didn't I did I hear that
Rogan was doing his next shit on YouTube
or something
that's interesting I don't know somebody
said that but people are always talking
that's not true then I'm sorry my guess
is like I don't know like what Louie's
doing just putting it on Louis ck.com
like you like you that's what Andrew
Schultz did yeah YouTube is demonetizing
things if like you say you know Andrew
Tate or fucking Marjorie Taylor green
they just have spider programs that just
if you say that most of the people that
do it are like queuing on people that
are pushing fake news or queuing on
conspiracy theories or whatever so
Comics get punished for it because
they're just words that they're getting
so if you say transvestite if you say
tranny they'll just like pull it out for
hate speech but like they don't know the
contact you might have been saying it's
wrong to say transvestite it's wrong to
say tranny and they'll still pull it out
it's too much bitch ass shit going on
like I don't know it's also like if
you're watching a special do you really
need to see the 5 000 comments where
everyone's trying to figure out my age
like I don't know it feels a little
distracting and I'll always be in the
comments I love it I'll respond and shit
I I like that shit yeah and it's so
funny it's like on Instagram too it's
like you know I'll be like I bet you got
like 99 requests of messages and shit I
respond to all them shits you know
that's what Dane Cook did he just
responded to everybody and like just
built that fan base and it just like
went crazy he was just responding to
everybody
so I just be like you like okay my
girlfriend wants me to rape her what do
you want to do what are you doing oh
yeah
dude thank you for coming hey man thanks
for having me
hey I want to come back and have another
four hour conversation I only want to
have comics on like I don't know I keep
wanting to quit podcasting I'm just like
ah I didn't want to bring back my
motherfucking podcast but I don't but I
don't know how to do it
because the way it was set up and all
that shit I gotta I gotta figure out how
to do it again yeah podcasts are a whole
fucking thing and then it's like I hate
I mean 100. it's the whole thing I mean
it's I've never looked I've made shows
before and like you kind of are able to
get through it because you're like oh
we're making ten we're making I mean we
used to do 24 a year that doesn't really
happen anymore but you're like I have a
Hiatus coming up or you know you're like
oh we have to summer off to like get our
brains fucking back in order this is
just like every week forever
used to look like this and so it was
like it had a cool little aesthetic to
it and all that shit oh this is where
did you shoot this at The Comedy Store
in the basement where all the with all
the asbestos
you know I got you in the in the mood
but it was turned the fuck up and I was
like man I gotta rebuild that shit
somewhere just get like a like a wooden
sort of Pristina like a type of thing to
put in the background and then just put
these Christmas lights and whatever the
fuck else is going on this is no no
offense but this isn't that hard to
recreate yeah yeah I hate to I hate to
Oh Oh I thought I had to have money to
recreate it I can do this right now in
my garage yeah should I buy my wooden
panel or something all we need are six
Post-it notes a couple like like weird
Baileys a couple masks from Oz
a couple tchotchkes it's been real hard
trying to bring that back nah
I feel like the green uh uh like foam on
the microphone that might take a second
to find oh no no I got those at a Guitar
Center for 12.99 those were easy the
thing the parts you think are hard or
easy what are the hard Parts is it the
and letting somebody let me use their
cameras is it the hard part is it no
well you can just do it here why don't
you just do it here I'm not driving all
the way up 30 an hour just to come here
and do this shit like almost turned
around come in here people fly to Austin
to do Rogan's show yeah yeah that's true
when you do a podcast you really find
out how you're perceived and like
sponsors you get you really find out
like who you are it's all for me dick
pills
pussy Lube CBD Lube a girl that I knew
when I first moved to LA like was just
like gorgeous model and like everyone
want to date her and she's just like
this Heartbreaker and I was like kind of
obnoxious like weirdo when I first moved
here and I've been hearing your name so
much I started a party and I just went
up to her and I was like so you're the
girl that everyone's like obsessed with
and she was like yeah I was like every
guy's like in love with you and she was
like
whatever and I was like so what is your
c i just let I was so wild at the time I
just was like why like I was so like
trying to figure out how to like be a
person
and I just was like getting information
in my head and I was like why and she
goes well
um I put Cherry chapstick on my pussy oh
oh and I was like thank you oh like I'm
so glad that I'm this like autistic that
I can while I'm over here trying to
taste that shit like I've been
put flavor that medicinal one
because it'd be cold I just like I feel
like thank you so much
like done the Cherry thing I feel like I
bought it and then I couldn't go through
with it because I feel like the cute
pussy him out a lot I feel the guy's
like is that cherry chapstick I'd be
like no like I would be like because I
remember I was so traumatized one time I
would put so much deodorant on before I
would like hook up with the guy because
I like I fucking stank sometimes and
dudes like when women stink a little bit
I know that right hell yeah
well I mean he's all fucking pits McGee
over here he's into armpits but but
um long time a guy oh my gosh Pat maybe
this is not just you I was hooking up
with some guy and he like was like
licking and he like lick I saw the
quarter of my you know when you're
hooking up with someone or kissing
someone you'll kind of like squint your
eyes so you see everything they're doing
but yeah but they think your eyes are
closed but you're really just like
peeping yeah and uh I feel like you're
both got into it
spying on each other but like kissing or
during sex I kind of pretend my eyes are
closed but I'm really just like trying
to spot spy and he went in and licked my
armpit and I had like Secret deodorant
on and I saw him go like
like I saw him
man I hate it's like I don't hate it but
it just it kind of weird me out when I'd
be like when I be like eating some pussy
and then the chick be like and then the
chick you know she's supposed to be
enjoying it but she literally looking
like this
I'm just like and she just seen me going
and she's just like
hey hey
I have to stop right
laughs
bitch come
on I'm staring at me by the way you're
like your double chin is making this
less fun I feel like when guys are going
down on you you Gotta Throw your chin
back that's fair you know you're not you
can't be put up make an eye contact with
a rubber band on that bitch keep it in
check all kind of shit man are you
touring at all soon are you at The
Comedy Store I'm at the comic store
tonight at 10 30. you know I feel like
this Bailey's was a hit hey I told you I
told you I do is your sister live in L.A
yes you like everyone yeah this is
limited edition she would love this it's
vanilla mint Shea she would love this
okay I'll give her I'll give her one
dude I'll send you with one this is a
delight hell yeah man that shit is fire
and then the mixer with the honey did
you mix it with the honey no I didn't do
that because um you did a little bit I
don't want to perish on my staircase
this evening oh I don't think you'll do
that I would like to survive another day
ah you will you you're stronger than you
think
it always comes out I'm just gonna say
this I was under the influence of what
is this honey Jagermeister yeah but
imported from Germany I don't know dude
Germans are fucking wild I mean yeah we
know maybe we're in everywhere hella Ed
Hardy or they used to work
Puma Puma yeah oh and Puma Ed Hardy is
not still in the mix I don't think for
real who was the other one Ed heart
there was a time a religion remember
True Religion
yes I remember True Religion I had to I
had to date men
I had to I had to be you know I had to
be I had to make out with men in clubs
wearing bedazzled shirts with dragons on
them yeah long sleeve
maroon and black tie-dye shirts with
bedazzled dragons damn Lucky them you
know okay hey remember Evisu no you know
what's that oh it was a it was a very
popular it was like true religion was
this and the ibizu was like Hood True
Religion I got pulled over for some
ibizu jeans just walking yeah but anyway
if I could pull it over for wearing them
jeans I was walking too and the cops was
like hey he was like pull up police
oh my God my husband had jeans like that
and let me tell you oh my God it was
awful I wore those jeans once and that's
why I blew his brains out
you ever been to Epstein Island
dude it's near the version that was
drowned trying to swim there for real no
I've never been oh okay
um I said yes
oh I mean you used
it after a cannon and all this shit
too I'm like whoever I was on Epstein
Island once let me tell you that imagine
there no they didn't let brunettes on
that island yeah they didn't let
brunettes over I mean it was Hillary
Clinton hair
blonde oh but I knew I knew I did know
about I did I feel like I knew before
anyone to know him No One Believes me
what did it man I knew because Elaine it
no billionaire marries a brunette
no billionaire marries someone that
looks like a boy from stranger things
yeah did someone says fishy it's like
fishy I've like seen enough like Rich
guys in Hollywood they don't man galane
was not I was like this is fit why is he
dating Janet from Three's Company this
doesn't add up and sure enough we find
out those brunette that brunette hey do
you be dating celebrities I haven't
dated any celebrities and every time I
talk about like having hooked up with
one it never makes the news but no I
haven't really dated celebrities oh okay
it sounds like I just I can't wear I
can't date men that wear makeup I can't
take it you wouldn't date machine and
Gun Kelly I love Michigan he's we work
together on something he's like he's the
best yeah I'd be too insecure today at
someone like that really yeah wow yeah I
just would be like what are we like
we're not yeah can you imagine following
Megan Fox I'm good
man I would be deep throat in those
pills though I'll tell you what diesel
right here I've just been like
I don't just think that it's so funny
and it's gonna be so cool that when you
have a hookup or whatever the fuck
happens one day you'll be like here let
me get a second and you come into this
room run into my pod Studio
it's my Pharmacy like it's Beauty and
the Beast
one of some kid that pretended to be a
doctor you're giving me pills yeah
because I want you to be happy but like
I don't know who it's weird because no
one kind of like warned me like hey like
once you become a successful female
comedian like No One's Gonna want to
date you yeah because like you know men
men you know women in power is you know
it's like
she's especially like what kind of man
are you if I'm a threat is she better
but when when you should just be in
there to get you know like I'm really
sure with shorts I'm wearing a shirt
with horses on it yeah but dudes don't
see that we see like oh she's a
successful woman there isn't anything
that I can do for her because we're
providers I can't find my keys you know
on a daily basis well maybe you need a
key looker guy you know I don't I can't
start my own car UK starts no I can but
I have to start your car for you can I
start joking it's just like a weird I
don't know I just yeah no one told me
like if you just so you know when you
make it no guy's gonna ever be attracted
to you yeah it's weird but when dudes
make it man we get all the whole except
for me you know what I'm saying but like
most dudes no that's not true Hey listen
most dudes get all the hole you get the
hole but they're like here's the catch
yeah you have to rape me all right well
bring your OJ Jersey like do you sign
make her sign something I mean it's like
can we maybe agree that this is gonna
get better stuff like that for sure yeah
it just feels I'm just out here having
fun like because I'm from here so
without your fake raping people
I'm freaking I mean you guys are so
fucking sloppy it is like shocking to me
you know that but you know what happened
to me Whitney is that since I'm from
here I grew up fucking here so it all
it's all it's all a blurt I know the
fuck the ones that don't it's all sex
you know like but if I were you know if
I moved out to make it out here and then
I would be more careful about who I fuck
out here all right I feel like we were
just winding down the podcast and now
we're back what do you mean the the grow
like growing up in LA and starting to
fuck in La you kind of yeah because
that's our fucking one when I started
fucking at 20 or whatever so like I
start so but it's late yeah it is kind
of late I was I was in a relationship I
was in a relationship with a girl who
wouldn't let me fuck or whatever so then
I wasted a lot of my fucking why didn't
you just rape her like this last girl
because I don't rape I'm consensualist
[Laughter]
wait so because you grew up in La you
think transactional sex was more you
know you know like like oh like all the
women are the same I mean they're not
all the same but it's like it's all just
sex to me or whatever because but do you
feel like women the women that you date
or have the same philosophy yeah I mean
I mean I ask all the time I love me some
consensual sex I love when it's mutual
if one person in the audience doesn't
laugh at every single joke I'm like fine
I'll leave fine like the idea of someone
not being I need someone to be so into
me that it's like I I the idea of
wanting to force someone to do something
that I want I just like uh how do you I
guess that's just I don't want to leave
nobody man because like
it's just bad it's illegal they got a
kink it's like feet people
what is the foot thing I don't fucking
know but I'll never ever get it now I'll
suck some toes and shit for sure but
he's like why I don't know I just like I
just like making a girl feel good you
know what I'm saying like what girl
thinks that feels good I mean females
like it yeah
I would give you CTE don't come near my
shit I hate it
but some girls like that shit or
whatever and you know like if they have
pretty feet like I'll do that shit but
like do you remember the movie Boomerang
yeah yeah where he would like lift the
motherfucking sheets up and shit like
that people like oh shit I gotta get the
fuck out of here shout out to Eddie
Murphy
shout out to Eddie Murphy ah the King
you think like when Eddie Murphy shot
raw I feel like he's like I'm just gonna
wear some crazy shit like this is never
gonna be a thing like not do you think
he knew it was gonna be the best special
ever or do you think he was just like
I'm gonna wear some crazy ass red
leather outfit I think he'd be like I
think he was just like this is fly
this is why I'm gonna wear this do you
think if he knew if someone said hey
this is going to be like thought of as
the great maybe the greatest special
ever
he would have worn that yeah
yeah so wild do you think if he wore
just regular clothes we would have been
as like
I'm fascinated by what Comics wear for
specials
me too oh me too sometimes I'll be
watching specials and I'll be like why
would they wear that like what I'm
trying to do the same thing what are you
why are you wearing an Under Armor it
says Under Armor and they're not paying
you like what is it drives me every time
I see a special I'm like I can't I can't
watch I can't sometimes I'll be like a
t-shirt and a blazer like why are you
wearing Uggs like I I don't I just for
me such a science of shooting a special
is picking an outfit that's going to be
timeless that you can run around in
that's not going to be distracting
that's going to just be like neutral and
classic I put so much effort into what I
wear in a special yeah man that's why I
went out there shirtless because it's
like people sometimes are so trendy
about it I'll look at specials I'm like
well you is that a slap bracelet like
why did you think that was gonna stay
it makes me nuts because it's like takes
you out of it yeah yeah the first thing
I noticed is like what's somebody
wearing I've been to like I I literally
you just you just don't wear anything
yeah you know you don't have to decide
what shirt to wear baggy pants and some
Doc Martens and a mohawk and a chain
I'll be like all right yeah uh pussy
you're like whatever the fuck you
talking about
I love the Gap in your teeth you really
like them I love it why they were well
I'm just I brought it because someone I
was with someone the other day an
actress who something happened where her
teeth started spreading like she stopped
wearing her retainer her Invisalign yeah
she had this Gap and it I thought it was
so adorable and gorgeous and like and
then we were talking just like uh I have
an appointment tomorrow I'm going to the
dentist to get this Gap filled in I was
like how did you do that and she was
like oh it just started spreading and
like it in photos it I just was like if
you have a gap how could you it is so
fucking adorable to me really man that
shit crazy uh uh nah I tried to close it
one time that shit her like a
motherfucker how I had these bands I
would wear bands or whatever and it like
and it'll close it get it smaller get
the smaller get it smaller and then that
shit hurt and it made my peep since I
was like fuck it up
I had clear braces when I was younger
which is like there's no such clear
thing as clear braces it's their
whatever color the food you just ate was
yeah yeah and like they don't work as
well whatever and um and then I did
Invisalign and it because I have the
fucking crooked as fuck tooth and
whatever it makes your shit itchy like
when it's moving it like is swollen and
it like yeah right when it your teeth
start to move it like that's it and it
make them feel like they like really
like loose and shit and I was just like
fuck it man I'm this is just me and then
my managers were like hey man so you
know um would you ever think about
getting your teeth fixed and I asked Mom
I was gonna close my Gap and I asked my
mama I said Mommy I said uh do you think
I should I say you think I should close
my gap or whatever and then she's like
why would you do that and then I said oh
well you know they said I would get more
rolls and stuff and movies she's like
but close that motherfucker because my
mama's all about them
famous musician ever doesn't she have a
big gap on her teeth yeah my mama so my
mama love money she's like well close
that motherfucker we know what your team
look like
she's like Fuck it we got a gang of
pictures of your teeth all right it's 10
o'clock at night yeah I know I love you
we have to go all right now we're just
saying I'm just I have to edit this Rose
Pat has off this podcast yeah this will
be a two-parter how about that split
this one up and now ending part two of
this podcast brought to you by Barry
honey we still ain't talking about shit
and Bailey's vanilla mint shake if
vanilla's vagina Shake I'm not drunk I'm
just like happy I want to be I'm present
and want to have a conversation and this
doesn't happen a lot dude this shit is
lit can I come back here put please all
right all right elephants will you help
me with the Ducks sure
all right so don't look for their second
hole
[Music]